I've told people to learn to use a
schedule and people often hate schedules
because they act as their own tyrants
right they say we have to do this
unpleasant thing and then here's another
unpleasant thing you have to do and then
you have to do this unpleasant thing and
you do that for about three days and you
think Oh tell with this I'm not doing
that you know and you fall off the wagon
that isn't what you're supposed to do
with the schedule you're supposed to use
it to design the days that you would
like to have if you were taking care of
yourself and so some of that is you know
you wake up in the morning and you think
here's five things I have to do that if
I don't do my life will be worse it's
like paying bills for example or taking
out the garbage it's like you have to do
those because otherwise things
degenerate so you got to put some of
those in the schedule because otherwise
tomorrow is worse than today and that's
a bad trajectory but you also want to
build in things you know you gotta act
in some sense like you're dealing with a
relatively recalcitrant nine year old
it's like so well here are some things
you have to do but here's some things
that if you do you could reward yourself
with and if you get the balance there
between obligation and reward right then
you'll find that you're motivated to do
the things and that's what you want to
do you want to do that so it's
sustainable across days and weeks and
months and so you got to you got to
treat yourself like a good boss would
treat a valued employee and not like a
tyrant would treat a slave because the
slave will rebel and you know people say
well I don't follow through on my plans
it's like well eh they're probably not
very well formulated and maybe you're
doing them because of an external moral
obligation or something not really your
plans right and B you're acting like a
tyrant and a slave and that's a bad
relationship to have with yourself so
you you want to treat yourself with some
well the same way that's the Golden Rule
write it treat yourself as you would
treat other people as you would have
them sorry treat other people as you
would like to be treated it works both
ways
you also treat yourself like you treat
other people properly so that's a
necessary thing and often people don't
do that